hello and welcome to the debate on Sky
News I'm Anna Jones here's our take on
developments brought together from
America the UK and from around the world
getting emotional and passionate about
politics Obama says there must be more
gun control
but what else is on the agenda as Donald
Trump and Hillary Clinton jostle to lead
each of their parties to eventually take
up residence in 1600 Pennsylvania Avenue
so you're not interested in politics
we'll never mind you're in for 10 months
of intrigue scandal swagger
embarrassment and exaggeration in
February voters get to start casting
their ballots as the u.s. presidential
election begins with the Iowa caucus and
ends on voting day in November well in a
moment we'll be talking to the
broadcaster and former mayor of
Cincinnati Jerry Springer but first as
usual the Democrat commentator Jeffrey
Robinson is in New York for us and the
conservative commentator Armstrong
Williams
is this week in Las Vegas welcome to
both of you Jeffrey to you first of all
as we kick off the new year how does
this presidential election campaign
stand do you think well it stands
exactly where it finished the last year
with Donald Trump almost almost within
sight of the finish line I mean it's
it's now six weeks he's got seven weeks
he goes to Iowa if he comes in second
he'll win New Hampshire a win South
Carolina and he'll go to Florida and
beat Jeb Bush and Marco Rubio in Florida
and that's about it game over at that
point but I love the way you talk about
intrigue scandal swagger and
embarrassment you you are not referring
of course to Armstrong and me in that
context I trust absolutely not
none of those the words apply to either
of you I'll so let me bring you in and
we should remind our viewers shouldn't
we that you're a business associate of
ben Carson one of the Republican
candidates and we'll talk a little bit
about his campaign later on but now more
generally what kind of a week would you
say this has been in the presidential
campaign well you know well the Donald
certainly announced early on the week
that there's no doubt that he will win
the nomination that he was challenged
former First Lady Hillary Rodham Clinton
in fact he posed the question this week
to mrs. Clinton and American people what
is the difference between her husband
former President Bill Clinton and Bill
Cosby so we know it's going to become
very salacious and very ugly and very
nasty as this process goes along but
that is consistent with mrs. mr. Trump's
personality he leaves nothing on the
table he leaves nothing unfiltered and
the fact that he's willing to go there
where most people would not dare
I think further endears him with his
bass because they feel that he's honest
it's what a lot of people think deep
deeply because as a matter of fact a
couple of weeks ago someone asked that
question and but Donald Trump has the
brass knuckles I asked and I think it
separates him and I think Jeffrey is
right it's very difficult seeing him not
getting the nomination given all the
things that he said that which people
seem to care about more and endeared
themselves to it I don't know if Jeff
you saw the image and on that cold place
this week where people waited in line
and below zero degrees waiting for Trump
and they packed the place because they
wanted to hear him this is a sign that
Trump is embolden and he's well on his
way okay well I think we're gonna be
talking a lot about Donald Trump aren't
we but let's bring in now Jerry Springer
who was born in London in 1944 he was
mayor of Cincinnati in the 1970s and
even considered running for the Senate
in 2000 and 2004 so Jerry Springer are
you fired up by this election well yeah
it's clearly that one of the more
interesting elections in my lifetime and
there's a lot of anger out there and
it's reflected frankly in both political
parties so the the angry people in the
Republican Party seem to be going to
Donald Trump in big numbers and the
angry people in the Democratic Party
seems to be coming to Bernie Sanders I
think in the end Hillary Clinton will
get the nomination and the Sanders
people will probably support it because
it's not that much of a difference I
think the real civil war is going to
take place in the Republican Party and
the reason there'll be a civil war there
is let's say either Trump or Cruz gets
the nomination even though they will do
very well in the South the reality is
it's pretty hard to see how their
politics wins in the north or even in
the far west and that being the case the
rest of the Republican Party the people
that are lower down on the ticket
they're going to be worried if you're
running like for the Senate or you're
running for Congress on the Republican
ticket and either Trump or Cruz is at
the top in the more moderate big States
these Republicans are probably going to
stay home they're not gonna want to vote
for Hillary but they're they not you
they're repelled by a Trump or Cruz so
they will stay home and in that case the
rest of the Democratic ticket will do
much better than expected the result is
the Democrats will get hold of the
Senate again they will elect the next
president and they'll even make inroads
in the US Congress so I think the
Republican Party itself is very
concerned if Trump or Cruz gets the
nomination and they may very well get it
but it doesn't sell over the broad
electorate of the American people it's
fair to say is it not that you're a
supporter of the Democrats from that
position what do you make of Hillary
Clinton's campaign she's she's well
ahead of her rivals isn't she but is
that because of her strength as a
candidate or do you think it's because
of the weakness of the rest of the field
no it's
look she's you may not like her politics
but it's pretty hard to argue that
there's anything in politics or what
goes on in world affairs or whatever
that she's not knowledgeable about she's
probably whether you're a fan of hers or
not probably the most well-informed
person running for president that hasn't
been president before like ever this and
so she's a solid well certainly
Republicans don't like her but I don't
know if she's that you know I know the
media wants to pick on that but honestly
I don't think she's that divisive among
the American public I mean in all major
groups you know she's gonna do great
with women she's gonna do great with
Hispanics great with african-americans
you know she's certainly left-of-centre
not as far left as Bernie Sanders I she
really isn't that you know divisive sure
that people that don't like her but
let's be honest whoever the Democratic
candidate would be there would be the
right-wing and Republicans who just
don't like that person and they would
find something about that person they
don't like that is inevitable but that
doesn't mean the American people see her
is this you know a very divisive figure
no I don't buy that what do you make of
the Donald Trump phenomenon if you can
put it like that I mean what
you put his popularity down to is it his
stance on immigration is it some of the
more controversial views that he's
putting forward or is it because he's
seen as an anti-establishment figure
some people see him as as fresh well
certainly he's anti-establishment and
let's face it ever since Ronald Reagan
said that you know government is not the
solution government is the problem
we have lived through thirty 40 years of
every election people saying how bad the
American government is you know and so
you have a whole generation of people
that have grown up basically - maybe not
hate our government but be really
anti-government so it was inevitable
that someone like a trump would
eventually rise to the top particularly
on the right side of the political
spectrum that wants you know government
to go away they were you know and that
being the case Trump is inevitable okay
let's bring in Jeffrey Robinson this is
a challenge isn't it for all the
candidates to try to appeal to those
people you feel somehow disenfranchised
by the system or weary about old-school
politics it's and particularly hard for
the likes of Hillary Clinton who is seen
as being such a Washington insider it's
even harder for the Republicans because
be careful what you wish for I mean it's
they've created this monster with their
war on women with their war on the
middle classes with they're trying to
trick the voters into into voter
registration scams they've created this
monster and what's gonna happen if one
of them if either Cruz or Trump doesn't
get enough votes by the time they get to
the convention and you have a brokered
convention and somebody says look let's
get Paul Ryan the Speaker of the House
let's bring him in what's at risk is
Trump saying wait a minute I've been
winning this thing I'm gonna go off as a
third party and I can afford to go as a
third party and he will destroy the
Republican Party in that sense it can be
very vindictive I don't know if Jerry
knows him I do as you know and I like
him as a guy
he's a guy's guy and he's a very likable
guy but you don't cross him because he
does become vindictive on the other hand
he took a pledge to support all of the
other Republican candidates if one of
them beats him and gets the nomination
you now have people like Jeb Bush and
Chris Christie and Marco Rubio and
others saying I'm not sure I can support
Trump if he gets the nomination they'd
be careful what you wish for it couldn't
happen to a nicer bunch of clowns
okay I'm strong Williams what's your
reaction to that how big a risk is there
there you know listen much respect for
Jeffery and Jerry Springer but you know
what listen they're they're blinded by
their allegiances to the Democratic
Party as much as they try to be
objective it's very difficult for them
and I think the difficulty that I'm
about to point to it is it is true there
are people that you will call on the
phone and they're embarrassed to say
they're supporting Donald Trump there
are people in the establishment of the
Republican Party like Jeb Bush and Marco
Rubio and others who could not find
themself support and given the kinds of
things that Trump has done to malign
them but I don't know whether
endorsements by the party early really
matters anymore and I think Jerry
Springer is right in this regard Trump
is a different phenomena and if you
think that because he's such a divisive
figures he's relying Latinos he's
maligned Muslims if you think that is
just the GOP right-wing base supporting
and affirming him you're lost in the
sauce crop Trump but believe it or not
has a lot of cross of appeal even among
blacks and Latinos and women and when he
took mrs. Clinton's sexist comments on
there are a lot of women in polls who
said while they have issues with him
they agree with what he said in terms of
analogy about her husband I think the
problem is that none of us really know
where this Trump phenomenon is gonna end
up I think if he is the Challenger to
mrs. Clinton I think she has much to
rhotic worry about because she's just as
divisive as mr. Trump in her own way I
don't think she can bank on women's
support her because she would be the
first woman I think in reality we are at
a crossroads we're in a time at a time
in American history we have no idea
it's gonna happen in November 2016 okay
a lot of questions Jerry Springer then
what's what's your best bet do you think
Donald Trump rate will win the
Republican nomination do you think he'll
win and if he does how would he do
against Hillary well you know I'm
probably gonna be wrong just because
everyone's been wrong this whole time I
I can't see Donald Trump getting the
nomination in the end and I don't know
how he's gonna be stopped but I think at
some point there are enough Republicans
that say this has been entertaining he
does buy into our anger he does
represent that but he's not a man where
we can permit his finger to be on the
button I mean this is the leader of the
free world and it's not a reality
television show
and at some point people are going to
say as much as I answer a telephone and
say yeah I'm for Trump when it comes to
Election Day in November they're not
going to vote for Donald Trump so I
don't see him winning now having said
that there could be some event that
happens tomorrow that could happen later
this afternoon we don't know that
changes the whole playing field but
right now it seems it seems to me that
Hillary Clinton is going to be the next
president barring something we don't
know about now but I think she's the
next president and don't strobe let's
just pick up on how your preferred
candidate you're a business associate of
ben Carson is doing he seems to be
falling in the ratings he's lost the
number of his campaign team some people
are blaming you for that what do you
have to say about that
well I am his business manager I
certainly was involved at the process of
dr. Carson having a shake-up
I mean mr. spring and Jeffrey all
understand that this happens obviously
it's at a late stage dr. Carson has been
struggling the issue remains if whether
or not not that he's had the campaign
shake-up and he's replaced many of his
top people can he turn it around Kenny
surged again in the polls can he get our
message Kenny when the trust back of the
event Jellico's and take support away
from Ted Cruz no one knows the answer to
that only time can tell but at least
we've seen even with rick santorum
leading up to iowa where it looked as
though he had no chance of winning Iowa
we
oh and he's found the way to win history
says that there is a longshot chance
that he could place first second or
third in Iowa there's a long shot that
he could play second win South Carolina
but no one knows it depends upon the
voters whether he can resonate with them
again and we just have to wait and see
Jeffrey there are still a lot of
candidates left in the field for the
Republicans fewer for the Democrats I
mean is that a problem in some ways for
Hillary Clinton and the two other
candidates there they're worried about
there being a sense of voter apathy it's
it's more interesting the Republican
race there's more going on well no the
Republican races the clown car it's more
amusing it's not more interesting it's
more dangerous and and the Democrats
will rally to that let me just say and
and where this is out of character
what's happened to ben Carson is not
Armstrong's fall Armstrong is probably
the only person who has been loyal and
faithful to him from the get-go and
stands by him I think that there has
been derision in the campaign and some
of the staff have lost the belief so
Armstrong's not to be blamed for that on
the other hand yeah ben Carson has
canceled his a bike in Ohio and he's
didn't go to Ohio the other day he was
in Staten Island to what he called
standing room only audience and there's
a photograph online of about 200 people
and a lot of empty seats so I I think
you can write Carson pretty much off
completely as for the Democrats Bernie
Sanders has got a lot to say and he has
been pushing Hillary slightly to the
left what he's talking about when he
talks about Wall Street and the 1% makes
a lot of sense to a lot of Democrats and
Hillary's gonna have to take that in
mind I think she's going to beat him but
it will change her and make her a better
candidate because of it okay well
gentlemen that hold those thoughts we've
got plenty more to come in just a moment
don't go away
you couldn't catch up with this guy nice
debater on Apple TV Roku and catch up
and of course on Sky News calm / us so
this political year has focused on
Friday November the 8th the day America
goes to the polls and votes for the 45th
president well Jerry Springer is with us
he's in sanity in Cincinnati rather
where he was mayor in the 1970s and
Cincinnati of course is in the state of
Ohio crucial state in any presidential
election in fact as I understand it Ohio
has hasn't voted for the loser in a
presidential election since 1960 what's
your gut feeling do think it'll be the
same this time around well I think I I
think the the truth is that no
Republican can win the presidency
without winning Ohio I think a Democrat
can win without winning Ohio but a
Republican can I think that's what
history is shown however if Kasich is on
the ticket he's not going to get the
nomination but if whoever the Republican
candidate is picks Kasich as the VP as
his running mate then I think it's
possible that Ohio could go Republican
it's a pretty much of a toss-up state
borrowing that as I said before the
demographics have changed and I just
think it's gonna be very difficult for a
Democrat to lose and I'm trying to be as
objective as I can be on that it's times
have changed and so I think it's a
democratic state unless unless Kasich's
on the ballot and then I think the
Republicans could win Ohio and of course
the first contest of this 2016 cycle
Jerry Springer starts less than a
month's time when we've got the Iowa
caucus how crucial a moment is that for
the candidates and how could we see the
campaign change from then on well the
Iowa caucus despite all the publicity it
gets is not determinant because a week
later is New Hampshire and normally
whoever wins Iowa loses New Hampshire
and then
we're back to Ground Zero I think the
big date to look at there are two dates
to look at if you're observing this
election and and the first is the
southern primaries that take place I
think it's March 1st someone will
correct me if I'm wrong but I think it's
March 1st and then you have a whole
bunch of southern states that is likely
to go to Cruz and if you put Cruz's wins
in the south together with his lead now
in Iowa then you have a combination that
the establishment is going to have to
figure out a way to stop Cruz from
getting the nomination because he'll be
way ahead in delegates that's one thing
to look at and the other thing to look
at is Super Tuesday which i think is
March 15th and by the way you have a
whole bunch of major states including
Ohio and Florida etc once you get past
March 15th the game may be over not that
someone will have locked it up in the
Republican Party but that that person
will be so far ahead that it would take
literally a civil war to stop that
person and that's when it's really going
to get to be interesting okay I think by
March 15th or the next day you're gonna
know who the candidate is okay Geoffrey
would you agree with that because you've
got the primaries then you've got the
conventions then you've got all sorts of
debates and so on what is the most
crucial point do you think in this
campaign well I would I would I would
just draw a different scenario the
juries I think that you've completely
disregard Iowa I mean Rick Santorum won
in Iowa and and you know where is he
it doesn't matter who wins in Iowa the
first real vote of as an election is New
Hampshire and that looks like Trump you
go to South Carolina and that's strong
you get to the Florida especially by
then you're gonna have people dropping
out it's gonna be interesting to see
where do ben Carson supporters go to go
to Trump and he's been nice to to Carson
that's gonna be a big blow to what to
Ted Cruz what happens when Jeb Bush and
Marco Rubio both get beaten in Florida
where do those supporters go maybe to a
third part a party candidate
I it's all up for grabs but I don't
think Cruz has got the advantage at this
point I think Trump does he's got enough
money to sustain himself and to make a
real push and once he hurts Cruz Cruz
may be permanently damaged in this whole
thing and there's no place else to go
for the right-wing Republicans but to
Trump the moderate Republicans you look
at a guy like Kasich he may be the only
one in the whole bunch who's actually
probably could have been a good
president because I don't think he is a
crazy Republican I think he's a man
who's pretty practical and brought
Medicare under Obama care to Ohioans
been castigated for it and that's
probably hurt him the most in that he
took Obama's money it's a fascinating
election and I think I think Ted Ted
Cruz sinks I think the others disappear
and I think by March 15th Donald Trump
Scott Sona I'm Jerry Springer I'm really
interested to hear your views on how you
think campaigning is going to change
this time around because obviously
social media is playing a bigger part
and we've seen Donald Trump's first
campaign advert coming out how much will
television play apart further down the
track of course we get the TV debates as
well what do you think will matter what
do you think will cut through to people
well television will have less impact
than it's ever had before simply because
the social media keeps getting a bigger
and bigger impact at this point no one
has spent more money on television than
Jeb Bush and that hasn't done him any
good at this point so I think television
is less of a factor plus when Trump gets
on he doesn't have to buy commercials
he's gets covered by the media all the
time so we I think the social media will
be critical Barack Obama never would
have been President of the United States
without social media the Democratic
Party back in eighth without social
media would not have gone the bigwigs of
the party would not have gone and said
we want you to be our candidate he
wasn't the institutional choice he was
able to raise money and have an
organization by using cell phones at the
time and then social media I think it'll
be the same this time although even more
so so that will be the big impact for
the
first time it won't be television it'll
be the social media and that's
interesting Jerry Springer you're a man
yourself aren't you of course so what do
you make of the debase they're
relatively new to us hearing so do you
would you do the television debates any
differently would you bring the Jerry
Springer approach to debates without
liven things up well you know I think
about if I look if I ever run against
Donald Trump you would have to build the
wall on the Mexican border because
Americans would be trying to get out so
that would be the problem but if you
made I think the early Republican
debates frankly were like my show and
that was embarrassing but the more
recent ones have been more serious the
debates get a lot of publicity but let's
be honest it has nothing to do with how
good a president you're going to be in a
debate you have to answer a question in
a minute and a half you don't ever want
a president that can make up his mind in
a minute and a half you want a president
well then there's a crisis will Greta
get the best experts around get the best
people around they'll consider all the
alternatives so the research they'll
figure it out and make a very reasoned
judgment that's what you want in a
president you don't want someone who has
prepared quips and it's funny and is a
great talk show host or a game show host
or reality show so the debates are
interesting to watch but they have
nothing to do with how good a president
you're going to wind up being ok I'm
going to ask the last question to all of
you Jeffrey to you first of all what do
you want to see during this campaign
what issues do you want covered and
ultimately you know what what do you
want to have come out of this campaign
for you to feel that your interest and
the interest of the nation have been
properly addressed I want to see Jerry
Springer run the campaign and bring on
strippers well that was short and sweet
anything else
Jeffrey tell us a little bit just
briefly about the issues that you think
are the most important ones and the ones
that are going to this campaign is going
to be run on well you know it always
gets down to the economy at one point or
another what was George Bush's line is
the economy stupid
it gets down to that we've got a
terrorism problem the national security
and there is a gun problem in this
country that has to be faced so there
are serious issues okay I'm strong
Williams what are your thoughts what
issues do you want to see raised what do
you want from this campaign you know
listen we have to address the the rising
issues of terrorism and how we fight it
at every turn we also often ignore the
racial tensions that again brewing in
the United States that are ignored and
which is just just not both well I mean
I mean you would think that in 2016 is
the last thing that we should be talking
about then you look at the rise of
anti-semitism in Europe those things are
connected and what is the source of it
and you know and through all that we
gotta work to make sure that people in
the lower class in the middle class have
an opportunity for the wealth class that
they can provide for their families that
they're given opportunities and that the
millenniums have a generation for
themselves these are issues that we must
deal with head-on and Jerry Springer
finally to you what do you want
discussed during this campaign and what
do you want to see happen to to really
ignite it well I think the issues you
that were just mentioned are the ones
but in in all fairness I don't think on
the issues of race the issues of
inequality the issues of safety I don't
see how what we're hearing from Donald
Trump is helpful I think it's just the
opposite in all fairness we're not going
to get along with each other better if
we start alienating anyone who is you
know not Christian and white if we start
alienating women if we start alienating
Hispanics we can't go after every group
and change what America is about America
is the Statue of Liberty it's not a wall
that's what we stand for and if we don't
get back to that discussion I don't know
what happens but I think in the end
Americans will go to their better nature
and we won't and we will be a more
inclusive country and not a country that
is just angry just mad and just mean
well Jerry Springer we really appreciate
your time here this week
it's very much D for joining us on the
debate and as ever Geoffrey Robinson and
Armstrong Williams thank you to you both
as well of course so that's it for this
edition of the debate you can continue
watching Sky News on Apple TV Roku and
catch up and of course on Sky News com
until next time goodbye